- [Anthony] Hello.
- Hello, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Group] Gary Vee!
- [Anthony] So Gary, really
quick, this is kinda like
destiny coming to fruition because
when I was in Pittsburgh,
when you had Crush It!
Originally the first one,
I set up and interview and you called in
and I was sick that day.
And the board op at the station called me
later in the day and goes,
you have some guy, Gary, on the hotline?
Who's Gary?
(laughs)
And I missed the interview
and I was so embarrassed,
I didn't even try to reschedule with you.
- I love it, man.
Don't worry at all, this
makes me super happy,
let's rock 'n' roll.
- [Anthony] Alright, so here's my deal.
We know about the book,
people are listening to this podcast
know about the book
because we're fans, right?
So I just want to go straight to Q&A
- Love it.
- [Anthony] Getting
some questions for you,
and let's just roll, okay?
- Love it, thank you.
- Alright, so, you are so in tap right now
with music, right?
You got a ton of artists that come in
for #AskGaryVee, come in
for DailyVee all the time.
When are you gonna start
being in artist management?
- Probably never.
You know, obviously, I'm
paying close attention
more than ever, it was
something that I was kind of
subtley into through the last 25 years,
then a little bit more into
and but it's always been a part of my life
but not one that I
would talk about because
I didn't know it as well
as business and sports.
But it was always there.
Over the last couple years,
especially the last 18 months,
to your point, I'm getting
real, real, real deep,
I think I'm bringing a lot of value.
I would be lying if I
didn't say that management
or creating a label has
run through my mind,
I'm an entrepreneur, everything
runs through my mind.
My intuition is, I won't do either.
But I also would be
shocked if I'm not doing
something in the music
industry over the next
three to five years.
My intuition is it's
gonna be different, right?
I got into the liquor store business,
but I did it by doing a e-commerce site
when everybody thought
the internet was crazy.
I got into the Madison
Avenue advertising world
but I did it by only selling social media
which was unsellable at the time.
So I think if I was to do
something actually official,
other than trying to bring
value to people that I like
who I think are gonna be big stars,
I think it's gonna come in a form
that people aren't expecting.
- [Anthony] Okay.
You mentioned a lot,
especially in your keynotes
and in your DailyVee's that basically
radio is now where TV was
20 or 30 years ago, right?
So, with that,
to me, as a radio personality,
'cause I watch all of your stuff,
like, religiously, okay?
And I haven't noticed a lot of guys,
I've seen you on The
Breakfast Club with Char,
I've seen you with Elvis Duran,
But those guys were interviewing you,
rather than asking you
questions specifically
about the industry that we're in.
- Yes.
- [Anthony] So, given the fact that
we have to reinvent ourselves,
what would someone like me do
to stay relevant in an era where
voice is gonna become king?
- It's actually very easy.
As long as you film yourself, or can,
or control it or not control it.
But to me, if I'm a radio personality,
and I have full control, not the station,
or I'm aligned with the station,
to me it's just having a podcast
and just filming the content
and putting it on YouTube and Facebook
and literally you're as
relevant as anybody else.
I don't see radio as this major negative,
as long as you also
vlog and have a podcast
and make social media content.
Period.
That's it.
- [Anthony] Right.
- So I would actually argue being in radio
is a huge advantage right now,
if you have the ability to film and also
create a podcast out of it.
- [Anthony] Well that's funny because
I have a podcast, right?
It's like, oh man, this podcast was fire.
It's gonna get a lot of listens, right?
'Cause I do have an advantage over
- Yep.
Joe Schmo.
Yep.
- [Anthony] I've done
it for my whole career.
But it's tough because
I'll even play a clip
of a podcast on the air,
and be like, yo, you have to check out
the rest of the conversation.
And there's a hoop I'm making
people jump through, right?
So, that's the hard thing was like,
I'm losing people.
- Yeah, well I mean I think,
look, as a radio personality, I think
everybody loves to talk
shit about the station
or the distribution or
things of that nature,
but what creatives forget is that
distribution's a part of it, right?
And being on Westwood One back in the day
or on iHeart, this,
distribution's part of it.
But to me, you still have an advantage
of being able to
no matter how much
friction you're creating
for somebody who's listening on the radio,
it's still more built in audience
than somebody who starts tomorrow
and is only at the mercy of winning
in a digital landscape.
So you have an advantage,
it's just that it's
not enough an advantage
for you not to be great
at Facebook ads, at doing collaborations,
showing up on other people's podcasts.
In today's world where everybody can win,
that means that everybody can win.
Which means you have to fuckin' be better
than ever before to break through.
- [Anthony] Right.
- Everybody's got a hot take
on the Drake Pusha debate.
Everybody's got a hot take on
the Golden State Warriors and LeBron.
Ben Simmons and Kendall dating.
Everybody's got a hot
take on Roseanne Barr.
In that world where
you're gonna have to fuckin' be better at
content and distribution.
And so yes it is hard.
And I always tell people, they're like,
man it's so hard.
I'm like, at least you have a chance.
In 1982, if you weren't
picked by somebody,
and one of the 17 people
that got to have an opinion,
you weren't heard!
- [Anthony] Exactly.
And I think, you know what's funny?
'Cause I know it's switching gears but
under the big umbrella I think it kinda
all falls under the same place.
You talk about '80s
brands coming back, right?
- Yes.
- [Anthony] It's happening
with K-Swiss and your shoes.
Thank you by the way,
because I flipped three pair
and made like $300 a pair.
(laughs)
- I love it!
- [Anthony] But it happened with K-Swiss,
it's happening with Champion.
But I was in the shower today,
and I wanted to take a bigger step back.
Shit, it's happening with
there's a new Atari
that just got released.
There's a new Intelivision coming out.
Cobra Kai is like the hottest
show right now, streaming.
So you nailed, you hit
the nail on the head.
But what I was wondering is,
the thing that's making
all of this happen,
is it direct to consumer?
So like you've got for instance,
the Atari 2600 which is coming back,
that's like on Indiegogo so
you buy that directly, right?
You have artists who
you have a lot on your show a lot,
they may not have the radio play,
but they don't give a
shit 'cause they're still
making millions because they're still big
because of Spotify.
- That's right.
- [Anthony] So if you
look at all these things
that they have in common,
with Netflix, don't need to worry about
getting a network to sign off on it.
It's on Netflix, or YouTube Red.
Is the direct to consumer
model the key ingredient
in all of these things coming back
and having that audience
that they didn't need to get approval
or a green light from
a bigger corporation?
- Yes-ish, but the bigger thing for them,
so there's two different things here.
Atari 2600 is different than
Tierra Whack or Gunna, right?
So, Tierra Whack and Gunna
and everybody else that's
emerging in hip hop,
the whole punk, rap movement,
Lil Pump, all this stuff,
they all build their brands
on Soundcloud, Spotify,
Instagram and so they
didn't need radio play.
What Atari and Nickelodeon and Pokemon Go
are playing on is brand.
Once something is in your
heart, it's in your heart.
- [Anthony] You know, it's funny
'cause I also DJ in the clubs,
and one of my biggest golden rules is
people don't know what they like,
but they like what they know.
- Correct.
And so, the best DJ to me is
the one that's gonna throw
three songs in the beginning that are fire
that I haven't heard of, and
he or she is putting me on,
and then out of nowhere, Journey comes on
and the whole place
breaks down too for that.
And they're two very opposite reasons.
It's like, don't play
in the fuckin' middle.
Either put me on to some new shit
that's fuckin' fire, or I better hear that
first fuckin' sound from
Hypnotize from Biggie,
or I'm out.
- [Anthony] Right.
So if I make, if I do,
'cause I had this idea,
and I haven't done it yet
but I want to bring it up to you
because if I make you,
'cause I have this idea.
If I make a mix of your
Monday to Monday playlists,
and I mix all the songs,
a lot of the songs that
are on the playlist
but I also take some of your
fire clips from keynotes
and edit it into the mix, will you
can I email that to you if I do that?
- Yeah, and I'll give you
some love for it, absolutely.
- [Anthony] Okay, so if I send an email,
in the subject
- Yep, yep.
Yep.
- [Anthony] Alright.
Questions from listeners and from people
that submitted to me.
Drew who is, he runs
a print shop, he says,
'how do creatives put a
price tag on their time?'
- You just keep asking for more money
until everyone says no.
(laughs)
- [Anthony] Exactly.
Kyle is in the health and wellness space,
he's observed trends and
products across the country
that aren't available in his market yet.
When it comes to introducing new products
in his market,
it is better to be first,
even though the product has been proven,
or better to wait for someone else
to take the risk of
introducing the product?
- Both.
- [Anthony] Okay.
- I mean the answer to
that question is both.
There's a lot
one's,
I'll give you a baseball analogy.
He's saying, is it
better to go one for five
with a home run, but I might also go
0 for five with no home runs,
or is it better to go two
for five with two singles?
- [Anthony] Nice.
- That's the question, and so
- [Anthony] Understand that one.
- Good.
(laughs)
- [Anthony] Okay, here we go.
A lot of your advice is geared
to, like, college grads.
- Yep.
- [Anthony] But I'm old.
I'm 40.
What would your advice
be for someone who's 40,
but starting out where
most of your audience
is starting out where they're 20 or 30?
- Well, it's interesting.
No joke, I don't know if you saw this,
I literally posted a video
today to 47 year olds.
- [Anthony] I did not see that yet.
- So, to me, everybody's going
through different things.
You know, to your point, in
the last 12 to 18 months,
I found myself producing a
lot more content to youth
than I have in the past,
which was usually to more
40 year old business people.
Look, I think the biggest
thing with 40 to 50
is that it's now you've lived life,
and you're still young as fuck,
and you're like, now what?
Right?
You have an entire second life to live
and it's a very interesting
time in people's lives,
where they have to be really retrospective
of how self-aware are they.
But honestly, I think 40's young, man.
I really really do, and so I would say
a lot of the advice I give to 20 year olds
maps pretty well to 40 year olds
which is, take some risks,
you've tasted some stuff,
happiness is the ROI.
And so, figure out what makes you happy.
Is it the pursuit of money?
Or is it actual money?
Do materials make you happy?
If materials make you happy,
is that really just insecurity
and you need to have
a BMW to make yourself feel good?
What's making you tick?
But I would say the biggest
thing that I would tell
any 40 year old is
you've got 50 years to live.
Please get the 'I'm
finished' or 'I fucked up'
eliminate dwelling, 'cause
you're just starting.
I really believe that by the way,
this is not some
motivational rah-rah shit.
I just think it's true, I just think
you've got 40 fuckin' adult years to live
that's 20 more than you've lived.
There's just so much opportunity.
- [Anthony] I think one of
your best pieces of advice
that really hit home with me
was when you said, perfection
is the enemy of speed.
- Yes.
- [Anthony] So many people
want to get shit perfect
that they just, ah it's not perfect yet,
so let's push it back.
And you lead a much better position
if you did it three weeks ago
and it might not be perfect,
but you had the product out there, right?
- Who cares.
- [Anthony] That's one of the
things I really took away.
This is for my wife.
What's the best bottle of
red for under 15 bucks?
- I'm a huge fan of Dolcetto.
D-o-l-e-c-t-to.
Dolcetto is a medium bodied red,
under 15 bucks that massively overdelivers
on the wine that it delivers.
- [Anthony] Got it, I'll tell her that.
Do you see a possible area to flip
with all of the Cleveland
Indian merchandise
that has a logo
- Are they?
Usually I'm good on culture.
Are the Indians changing their
logo or changing their name?
- [Anthony] So they
have the get rid of the
Chief Wahoo.
So the hats that they have now
- My intuition on it is
the answer's gonna end up being no,
'cause there's just,
it's all supply and demand.
This is why everybody got fucked
with 1987 to 1994 baseball cards.
We were all told they
were gonna be worth money.
Thus, we all saved 'em, but
there was a million of 'em.
There's so many fucking
pieces of content out there
with Chief
If you look at the things
that are collectible,
I'll give you one of the great inside tips
on how to make money on collectibles.
- [Anthony] Alright.
- Buy shit
that is towards the end
of a franchise being cool.
For example,
right now I would buy
an enormous amount of
2018 original produced Harry Potter shit.
'Cause it's towards the
tail end of its era,
which mean they're producing
these Harry Potter things
in much lower quantity.
For example, the first Star Wars toys,
the most valuable Star Wars toys
were the Power Of The Force figures
that were made in '85, '86.
'Cause nobody gave a fuck anymore,
and they didn't make a bunch,
and they got destroyed
and they got thrown out.
The most expensive, you
know the rubber wrestlers
from the '80s that I'm obsessed with?
They're called LJN's,
the most valuable LJN's
are not the first ones,
they're the last ones.
They're called the black card series.
They were towards the end of wrestling,
so people, you need to buy things that are
made in limited supply,
but the equity of the
franchise is very great.
So whatever is made towards the tail end
of something being cool in
culture is what you want to buy,
and then recall it on
the flip 20 years later
when it's back!
- [Anthony] Genius.
I was gonna ask what would
be a very practical tip for
flipping in money, that's it right there.
- That was super practical
and I gave you even more example,
like a hardcore one.
Harry Potter merch,
that is made 2018, gold.
- [Anthony] This pops up on like
the Gary Vee Audio Experience,
you're gonna make my freakin' year.
(laughs)
- It probably is.
There's two to three very
good pieces of content here.
Baban's shaking his head wildly,
so I think you're gonna get some love.
- [Anthony] Well you know,
we do have one of our guys
that works for you, D. Kirk.
We had him on a podcast
literally a week before
he went to move to work for you.
- Based on the Reddit virality.
- [Anthony] Yes.
- Amazing.
- [Man] That's why we got the
- I love that.
- [Anthony] And you know,
I love what you're doing with Twitch.
We just started a Twitch station
we started a Twitch
channel for radio station.
My boss was lookin' at me
like I had a dildo on my head.
(laughs)
Why does a radio station gonna
have a video game channel?
- Best thing.
- [Anthony] That's where attention is.
- Of course!
- [Anthony] Why don't
we go there?
- Of course.
Did you happen to catch the
fact that I played Tyler
in Nintendo Hockey last night and beat him
20 to seven in game one,
and then he told me I'd
never beat him again.
Next game it was 12 to one
when he had to mercy rule out.
- [Anthony] Dude I'm
just waiting for you to
create your own track,
the VaynerMedia track
in Excitebike.
- By the way, Excitebike
is so fucking gangster.
- [Anthony] It's the best!
It's like the best bad game ever!
- Best.
- [Anthony] You can't land that jump,
you gotta always tumble down the hill,
and it's like fuck!
- Best.
- [Anthony] Man, dude,
so much great content.
I appreciate you making the time for us,
I appreciate you taking the time,
I know you're super busy.
The funny part is I went to New York
for a Z100 Jingle Ball.
I tried literally every attempt
to find a record rep who knows you.
None of my record rep contacts know you!
(laughs)
I'm like, guys, you're
in the same fuckin' city!
And then the funny part was,
the hotel that I stayed at,
one of your videos, I
forgot which one it was.
It was a Daily Vee.
But there was like snowflake
lights on the light poles.
- Okay.
- [Anthony] So I'm like, shit!
Gary V's around here
somewhere, cause I've seen
(laughs)
your DailyVee.
- I love that.
Thank you man.
This was super enjoyable, guys.
I appreciate it.
(hip hop music)